[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuántos de nosotros hemos dedicado por
lo menos un tiempo a reflexionar sobre
qué dedicarnos y qué estudiar sobre todo
algún momento de nuestra vida quién se
ha preguntado eso
ok
cuántos de nosotros estudiamos lo mismo
o se dedican a lo mismo que sus padres o
sus abuelos
parece tener obtener que algunas
personas parece no tener mucho sentido
actualmente este tipo de preguntas si en
la realidad y en el mundo en que vivimos
y es que jugando con los los hijos mi
esposa y yo ambos muy pequeños de hecho
el mayor de ellos de cuatro años lo
confieso hemos tenido ese horrible y
culposo pensamiento que tiene todo padre
que se irán a dedicar cuando sean
grandes
es difícil saberlo en base a sus
intereses actuales de dinosaurios rojos
que son amigos de trenes ranas y
serpientes
pero anteriormente no era una decisión
difícil todo lo contrario era una
decisión sumamente sencilla que estudiar
generación tras generación de abuelos y
padres pasaban conocimiento pasaban
técnica y pasaba información al acerca
la que sigue todo en un ciclo durante
mucho tiempo
entonces inclusive durante más de mil
años navegar con brújula no cambió
absolutamente nada nos podríamos
imaginar navegantes y comerciantes
durante mil años aprendiendo exactamente
lo mismo una y otra generación durante
la edad media la gente vivía según la
profesión que tenía según en los barrios
entonces que ha cambiado
porque ha dejado de funcionar esto o
porque esto actualmente no es tan
relevante
actualmente hemos avanzado enormemente
en ciencia tecnología e innovación
probablemente esto es no es nada nuevo
lo que sí es interesante es que parece
ser parecemos un poco más perdidos en
ese aspecto parecemos como sociedad que
hemos perdido un poco el rumbo en esas
partes
y no sabemos qué es o qué dejar a las
siguientes generaciones esta idea este
cautivador ideal respecto al desfase de
la ciencia la tecnología y la innovación
es bastante nos parece bastante es
ordinaria todos no puedo ver en
investigaciones lo podido ver con mis
alumnos en la academia lo he visto con
mis coladores colaboradores más jóvenes
en una empresa que se dedica a generar
tecnología y en última instancia lo
visto como padre últimamente con mis
hijos
ciencia tecnología e innovación la
ciencia la ciencia la podemos entender
como cualquier cosa que nos ayude a
entender por qué enfermamos la
tecnología la tecnología nos ha
permitido construir los automóviles
construir nuestro medio de transporte y
la innovación la innovación está en este
instrumento que nos da a la hora creo
que esto es estos ejemplos son sumamente
sencillos y de entender para todos dicho
estamos sumamente familiarizados con
ellos inclusive no somos expertos
probablemente pero podríamos decir cómo
funciona el automóvil cómo funciona un
reloj o inclusive platicar un poco sobre
enfermedades y si hiciéramos esta
pregunta dos o tres generaciones atrás
creo que la misma audiencia contestaría
lo mismo
esto es porque nos movemos en ciclos
ciencia tecnología e innovación se
mueven en ciclos y no sólo eso el ser
humano se mueve en ciclos el psoe el día
la noche los gobiernos nacen caen las
compañías crecen crisis económica es
decir hay un ciclo continuo que empuja
al que sigue estos son los patrones y se
han venido haciendo durante un
determinado tiempo
tomemos ciencia tecnología e innovación
la ciencia lo podemos definir muy
sencillo es todo aquel conocimiento que
pasa por un método científico hablan
enseñados desde ser escuela después ese
conocimiento práctico se vuelve
tecnología
y posteriormente con un determinado
tiempo y usado por todos esta técnica y
esta tecnología surge algo que llamamos
innovación
lo interesante es que el ser humano
todos nosotros durante el transcurso de
la historia hemos jugado un papel
fundamental en cada uno de ellos la
mayoría los sucesos en la historia se
podrían ver así
[Música]
la familia los maestros y la comunidad
ha generado conocimiento que con el
tiempo no lo ha dejado a estudiantes e
hijos
a profesionistas que nos entregan esta
técnica posteriormente con el tiempo
organizaciones empresas y universidades
han generado esta innovación y así se
sigue el ciclo y estamos generando una y
otra vez de esta forma
pero hace algunos años
esto parece que no tiene mucho sentido
tomemos anteriormente
hay dos ejemplos que nos pueden explicar
esto la ingeniería durante más de 1400
años no cambio en su papel el objetivo
principal de la ingeniería que es
inventar y construir prácticamente
maestros artesanos carpinteros lo han
venido haciendo durante mucho tiempo
posteriormente de 150 años atrás la
ingeniería industrial ha seguido el
mismo ciclo
el estudio de la medicina en dos
milenios no cambió su propósito
fundamental curar y salvar vidas
prácticamente hasta el inicio de la
medicina moderna y el descubrimiento de
la penicilina en este gran ciclo como lo
veíamos todo el mundo sabe cuál es su
papel
los maestros sabían exactamente qué
enseñar a sus estudiantes los padres de
familia y los abuelos sabían que debían
de transmitir a las siguientes
generaciones las personas sabían cómo
comportarse sus medios de trabajo y es
decir cada parte del ciclo se cumplía
comunidad familia estudiantes todo
algunos años atrás esto parece que dejó
de tener mucho sentido es decir ciencia
tecnología e innovación empezaron a
comportarse un poco distinto años atrás
y el rol ese rol histórico que teníamos
nosotros las personas dejó de tener
sentido y eso nos dio un poco de
incertidumbre y parecía dejarlos un poco
perdidos
y es que ahora las ciencias médicas
parecen que tiene el único objetivo es
hacerlos vivir para siempre las
enfermedades se empiezan a ver como
simples fallas técnicas que pueden ser
corregidas con tecnología
estamos en una carrera por construir
cosas más inteligentes que nosotros que
a su vez puedan construir cosas más
inteligentes
actualmente hemos democratizado
totalmente el conocimiento hasta tenerlo
en las palmas de nuestra mano
lo interesante es que parecemos no
distinguir qué es real y que no es real
pero lo alarmante es que parece no
importarnos
en esta parte
cada vez más somos asistidos por
software y hardware inteligente en
nuestro trabajo es sumamente común y la
gran pregunta no es qué tan inteligente
o que tanto nos va a ayudar ese hardware
y software en el trabajo la gran
pregunta es cómo vamos a colaborar y
entendernos con nuestro nuevo compañero
que ya no es humano
hace algunos años
una gran cantidad de medios de
comunicación comentaban data scientist
es la carrera del futuro necesitamos una
gran cantidad de data sciences
hace seis años hoy este año algunos de
sus medios de comunicación dicen ya no
necesitamos más datos agentes en sólo
seis años las primeras generaciones aún
están regresando y en seis años
se dice ese cambio tan importante y la
familia parece cada vez más lejano este
rol histórico que tenía la familia de
entrenar de entregar un conocimiento que
podría servir prácticamente para la vida
diaria
este nuevo ciclo esto que estamos
viviendo actualmente
resulta un poco desconcertante
el conocimiento parece más transformado
en aprendizaje
recuerdo pocas veces si no es que
ninguna donde en una entrevista de
trabajo a un posible candidato haya
hecho la pregunta de qué estudiaste
pero sin embargo recuerdo cada una de
las ocasiones donde pregunte que puedes
aprender
la innovación y el tiempo avanza
vertiginosamente durante mucho tiempo
matemáticos financieros y nosotros los
economistas hayamos hecho cálculos cada
vez más complejos y lo aprendíamos en la
escuela para poder entender el sistema
económico proyectar un riesgo financiero
o hablar sobre política monetaria
ahora todo eso puede ser hecho por un
algoritmo inteligente cada vez menos
entendemos nosotros de qué trata ese
algoritmo o cómo está funcionando ese
algoritmo
y los problemas los problemas avanzan
cada vez más rápido de lo que pudiéramos
entregar una solución a escala global y
es así como tenemos una isla de basura
plástica flotando en el océano con
mayores posibilidades de que se
multiplique a que como sociedad como
gran aldea global pudiéramos entregar
una respuesta
vivimos en un nuevo ciclo este ciclo
está evolucionando y tenemos muchísimas
más preguntas que respuestas
definitivamente estamos a una prueba de
error de conectar de nuevo familias
escuelas y comunidad con un nuevo
aprendizaje porque ahora parece bastante
distinto el objetivo de la ciencia la
tecnología y la innovación nos deja una
gran cantidad de retos y formas de nuevo
de entender los diferentes aprendizajes
es decir parecemos cada vez más que
vivimos una realidad que nos deja gran
incertidumbre
pero es una realidad que continuamente
estamos creando gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]